always pay attention to the person
that's given the advice not the advice
no but uh man how are you are you I'm
real good I'm excited I'm happy to meet
you I appreciate that
how are you Tommy Tommy yep levar Lamar
would somebody replace me why is that
because I really believe he was
literally just teaching so he has a
class that he this teacher wants to take
everywhere
keep took the class he's teaching people
how to make money he makes a ton of
money himself he went to complex Khan
showed up bought one pair of shoes maybe
$7,000 I 100 105 105 like he knows what
he's doing and he wants to take it
across the country and like TJ he's
young kids and he literally I gave him a
penny just RAM Grammy right through it
he was a teach them how to use their
money right use little money teach them
how to make the flips really patient
because it gives a negative stigma that
like a lot of times I know I've heard it
personally just all social media they're
like you're a stupid kid that stands
outside of a store for hours you're
that's so dumb for sneakers like why
would let's start there before we go
further I'm excited for this to you yeah
first of all the most interesting part
about that is and thank you that's what
I see that's what like like like like my
biggest thing is on that like for
everybody like you know and obviously
you know have a lot of love for to
resell game to I mean the whole thing is
so crazy for me like just I mean just so
crazy that everything that I was as a
kid that made no [ __ ] I mean I if you
understood how off the [ __ ]
reservation I was as a kid like I'm like
a normal guy so I had friends and
everything but I was so different like
like like like to the extreme like I
didn't like pretty girls like me in high
school I don't want to talk to them
because I wanted to go to Kmart and buy
Shaquille O'Neal figures to sell on the
flea market on Saturday like like you
know so my big thing on that is on that
is like who gives a [ __ ] what people's
opinions are yeah it's so funny I'm a
winner
and when I Drive like to like the
airport at like 5:30 in the morning and
I like I'm like a and I look outside I
see a line I'm like winners I swear my
[ __ ] children that's what goes right
through my head I look I'm like winners
right like remember remember remember
what what year did you AJ comes to our
Cacho five yeah before your grills calm
do you remember we had a site called
beep the baby bathing ape calm yeah
remember that didn't you and AJ come
down the first pape store in SoHo when
it opened its weren't open first I
remembered it when it open like yeah I'm
with you like yes oh but because that
day like you said winners those same
kids that are getting up at 5 o'clock
Adem I want to hire all of them yeah
that's what I'm saying so like those are
the only ones I want to talk to like
look if you got an A and like science
like I don't want to talk to her about
this but if you like woke up at 6:15 in
the morning and you figured out how to
pay off the guy at the [ __ ] front let
me ask you a question what do you want
to happen
no no I'm talking macro for you
selfishly not selflessly yes selfishly I
want to impact and basically like that
guy Rex was deep dictated long you don't
sell it then you don't think not when
you just told me that's what you want I
mean but I'm also looking at huh huh so
let's keep playing okay
that's why I got excited is but I'm also
looking at it from a standpoint of
impact is more important to meet in like
having the monetary value so don't sell
it but how I get it out there if it's
free more people are gonna come okay
that makes sense make sense because I
can get investment from okay I see where
you won't I know where I'm ok let's play
right yeah like like I understand but
what I need to know is what you want to
happen right so the thing that's
interesting about you and why stood up
and got excited and just did my little
thing is cuz I think we have a lot of
similarities like I already knew and I
knew a little something but I can smell
the reason I mean is I
the reason I do what I do is I have to
touch it the reason I was bad at school
like I have to do have to touch it this
whole company
you know like sucks like a bill 200
million dollar company but I had to do
it and do all the [ __ ] that comes along
with it cuz I got a touch [ __ ] you have
the ability to make money that's the
point of the course in itself right that
means you're dangerous when it comes to
content see the thing that's dangerous
about me compared to all the other
motivational inspiring people is I don't
want your money because I know how to
make money elsewhere which means it's
the reason I'm impacting the most people
because money does two things for the
course one it's a financial barrier the
people we're talking about there's a lot
of people that 250 is real money number
one especially if like you know if the
attraction is you know this is a game
that's great to like start that process
this is not for millionaires you know
like it's not for my employees know it
is but you know what I mean right
because especially cuz like you have a
great point there which is time
arbitrage right this is a great game one
thing I was always bad at I'm still bad
at it and I turn it into my strengths is
I don't manage my time well which
weirdly worked out for me in the end
because I still continue to give love
when I shouldn't be but what's really
interesting to me about you is money
does two things right two things one
it's a it's a restriction twice one it's
money and that's a percentage of people
especially with your flavor it's gonna
be restriction just a good percentage
your audience right number two for the
rest of them that can afford it for more
than half of them it puts you in a box
the box well you're full of [ __ ] I don't
believe you you're just doing this
because you want my 250 and that just
leaves you with twenty percent of the
hundred percent that you're trying to
reach the end and and and you know
what's been so fun I was a whiz kid my
whole life right three thousand dollars
some baseball cards when I was twelve
went into my daddy's looked her store
and [ __ ] blew it up I'm you know I'm
starting to make that transition where I
get to be like the old guy right it's
[ __ ] rewarding as [ __ ] you know
because like that moment that double
smile for me it's the best cuz I know
I'm right and I know you know I'm right
right now if you don't backtrack and say
listen Gary cool but like honestly on a
real cake of course I want to inspire
but I feel great about some for 250
because what I'm doing is that's a deal
it's worth five fairly you can tell me
anything nothing makes me upset
nothing people can tell me anything
really I don't think who the [ __ ] am I
to judge anybody about anything I mean
that for real that's why I like
everybody cuz I don't like anybody and I
love everybody it's the same [ __ ] my
opinion doesn't matter like kind you
know what I mean it's just humility like
Who am I to judge but this is why in
these like this is what we really need
to think about so let me explain if you
know what the the other part that comes
along with the advice I'm giving you is
a totally different upside $250 a head
even if it becomes two thousand a head
cuz everybody's winning and you know you
can rate right times ten thousand people
still a hundred thousand real money
wealth mansions life right still fall
short if you're good enough if you give
it all the way for free because then
where your life ends up when you're 52
is you actually own supreme or Puma
okay cuz you build the biggest audience
right I mean that's kind of what's
happening right now like right like at
the end of the day people coming to me
anything that I work for those people
they think that I work for these like I
don't and it's just based off of my
association at how like supreme I said
uh babe idiot yeah any of the street
wear brands that basically have they
think they're feeding you place yeah
it's me feeding myself cuz I'm just that
dedicated to what I do I couldn't agree
more
yeah I would I never even crossed my
mind that you were with them like that
you can win if you're the best at what
you do right and I think that at the end
of the day I'm one of if not the best at
what I do I'm definitely the most
notoriety notable of all the people that
I do with and so here's what I would say
well every day people tell me why the
[ __ ] do you tell everybody the best [ __ ]
for free and I'm like because 99% of
people aren't gonna do anything about it
right and there's an abundance one of
the reasons psychologically it would
make sense for you to charge is you know
you're also creating a supply and demand
issue that takes away your own advantage
right I'm telling you the move up is to
get as many people on as possible and
create no friction there's always gonna
be something else I'm about to make case
was hard to get
oh no that's this literally what I just
said about the code is always gonna be
something that that's literally yes I
agree with that
the end damn you to Vince the end got it
that's it the secret is the reverse of
what people think it's some Bible [ __ ]
they were right just give it all away
for free get it all back you know so you
think I should go you think I should
focus more I think the biggest mistake
that smart people making right now is
charging their audience and that's
what's coming to everybody naturally but
I don't think you know I think it's
because it's like music the music should
be free that's how you make real money I
would [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] yelling on
people online you know
BitTorrent my book if you can't afford
it
no like I'm happy that some kid just
heard me say that and you're gonna keep
it in the edit and like I want them to
hear that because what I want him to win
I want her to win do I lose money cuz I
just said it yep or there's some people
they don't even know what that is and
they just googled it like oh [ __ ]
like yes but like I mean it I didn't
like the book because I'm gonna make the
[ __ ] [ __ ] four dollars per book
remember [ __ ] is my cut with the
publisher I wrote it because some people
learn better reading a book than
watching my [ __ ] videos I [ __ ]
hated recording my audio book I didn't
record it for the [ __ ] couple more
sales I recorded it because some people
don't want to read a [ __ ] [ __ ]
book but they'll audio the [ __ ] out of
me and two [ __ ] gym sessions and walk
in their [ __ ] dog the content is the
magic it's the gateway drug I get 150
thousand racks a talk because I gave
away my [ __ ] for free while [ __ ] are
trying to sell $400 ebooks out there
okay well then you better [ __ ] listen
you got it yeah how they want it in
every format I'm taking out all the
costs how many people we got I got 20
people on my team helping me make
content why cuz I'm gonna give it to you
with every [ __ ] format audio vlog
vlog on YouTube vlog on Facebook podcast
Google Apple Samsung you Instagram cool
snapchat good LinkedIn yep medium good
my blog yep Twitter yes what's everybody
else doing they get a little bit of a
fan base on and so remember that good
I'm good here I'm good here
okay that's it that's fine well you can
do an Instagram it's not relevant do
nothing else but continue to flip and
make money and give away everything you
got to everybody on social media at
scale in a way you've never I would tell
you straight up like straight up take
not only sell [ __ ] and make money but
take 90% of the profits and pour it back
into a team and ads on social to give
away [ __ ] for free listen what I'm
telling you make a million dollars make
a hundred thousand dollars I have no
idea how much money you're making take
not live worse than you did two years
ago
there's the vise busy official advice
make the money you're making live worse
than you did before they started
happening take the money
run Instagram and snapchat and Facebook
and YouTube ads for people to see the
[ __ ] for free that's my official advice
you're too young that's why you got time
and that advice is predicated if you're
ninety eight year old Charlie do not
take that advice that advice is strictly
for you
do you mind you don't like careers based
on mic point I didn't make that much
money I built a [ __ ] business for my
dad I have enough money I didn't own the
business so I didn't go to a bank and
get a loan I wasn't making that much
money but I lived humble this [ __ ] and
what did i do I saved the little I saved
so I saved thirteen thousand this year
nine thousand that year right finally
had a little something and then Facebook
and Twitter came across my desk and I
[ __ ] struck had I with the little
[ __ ] money all these kids make more
money than I did I'm being serious
people don't understand people like oh
you had a liquor do you eat don't listen
him yet he got it I built my parents
liquor store for them
I got nothing that you would spend in
you spent a fortnight Bert was about
eight to ten cents then they were there
like eight to ten dollars now that you
could have basically major your parents
liquor store even that much bigger a
hundred thousand percent one hundred
percent so I'm just got a hundred
percent so I get worried the reason I'm
ranting right now is I think people
think I'm giving advice from my perch
now I'm giving advice I took people
trying to come up for excuses to why not
to work people trying to come up with
excuses why to buy listen you could buy
off weights all day if you can afford
them right but if you're buying them as
the like you've been saving up or
robbing somebody to get them you lost
totally oh and it's happening right like
I'm saying it your say it like it's
happen weird it's unbelievable or ten
years away shit's gonna be so different
man yo shit's gonna be so different it's
already so different you guys are young
like I saw it like hip-hop was one thing
you were tough and that's it there was
no other thing guys you couldn't do what
the [ __ ] you were doing a band down and
you're like [ __ ] shoot you you
[ __ ] it's like you know like like
like there was one there was one there
was one move
there was one move they were all in
person you more Timbo's you were starter
that was one blue every was the same and
if you weren't that you made up your
story that you were if you had music
skills and you want to be a rapper
and you lived in the suburbs but your
aunt lived in the hood you visited one
time in the hood and that's where you
said you were from right that's right
cuz there was no option now all you guys
can do whatever the [ __ ] you want yeah
you're gay good trans good [ __ ] want
to dress like Jimi Hendrix cool
[ __ ] look at you guys it's the best
that makes me so happy now people could
just be with you what can anyone do
right now and hip-hop that's gonna feel
that you can nothing nothing nothing you
want to be you want to be cardi be good
of course what like what what are you
gonna judge nothing you weren't a Tina
Turner t-shirt she's the most fire but
you know like it's people don't get it
it's the best hip hop's the most the
most accepting the most I love it but
just don't be confused you got to make
that successful you can't just say
you're a rapper that's why Sports was
the best nobody's like yo I'm a
basketball player if they weren't in the
league you know you know but music I'm a
rapper yeah but you but on the flip side
what's amazing is on the flip side of
everything we're just saying you are
maybe just one SoundCloud song away you
are that's crazy
you are just one viral [ __ ] video
away from being able to then build a
huge career around music around it what
are we living through right but you got
to put yourself out there all these
viral hits they made [ __ ] before that
fat kid was around before it was just
our time
I look at it like a recycling most the
most industry's going to the like a
recycling that's their 100% always you
know why my man because humans are
humans yeah it's all the things [ __ ]
there's only like nine or ten like
people always like you always got you
really got a cute name like cuz there's
only 13 answers you know it's just
psychology like either you had too much
or you had too literal either you love
your parents ready hate your parents
next I can give you every answer after
that right what the internet did was it
allowed the ones that didn't have as
much get the advantage that's what got
[ __ ] up cuz we're hungrier yeah and
nobody's stopping us now you season
nothing you have to go out stop people
think of justice isn't a hitter day all
day and just do it happen and they can
but if you're really smart and you go
outside and you know you know what all
those things are they're just talking
about balance
it's just balance right they just
balance I haven't read the articles yet
but like what McGregor did yes traits
probably just one to like I don't know
I'm still just reading headlines but he
probably just went too far and then it's
like ah [ __ ] it he did right what
happened a barricade through the window
a lot of the fighters was on the bus and
like hustling dudes face up with the
glass we huh he crashed the press
conference right which is kind of like
WWF cool whatever but then it like
escalated out into like where the buses
were he breaks through security grabs
like a barricade and then like throws
the [ __ ] through like a window not a
tour bus yeah his throws it through the
tour bus window in the back of the bus
though where everybody the Signet and it
cuts um got like three people can't
fight cuz I should I know
yeah I wonder whose face got all cut up
he suffered like yeah so he wild out I
guess you throwing it at the luggage
holder you know I want to get some rot
nah right this glass cuz he's [ __ ] on
the bus he's happy now he's hacking
culture he's smart he smashed he's smart
if he didn't throw it through the window
and it just hit the back of the bus we'd
all be like he's [ __ ] a gangster he
got it but it's all about balance but
it went through the glass and then
injured other people and now you're like
that
got it balanced and then the
conversation starts yeah and that's when
the threads on Twitter go up and that's
when everybody on the instance or on it
so what do you think interns like
because at the end of the day I still
want to be able to like package this
properly I'm taking to explain oh you're
trying to play checkers I want you to
play chess packaging means monetizing
and I'm trying to make you monetize in a
different way you know what I mean
packaging this to monetize is fine and
your mother like you're more to welcome
but my theory is the attentions worth
more that's what I mean
well that's it eliminate the friction so
look what I do I eliminate the friction
between me and my audience I don't
charge and I put it everywhere in every
shape and form the end that's why I'm
the ultimate I really believe that I'm
the one that's eliminating the most
friction not looking for from and by the
way also when you're not asking for
money it just changes the relationship
yeah everybody's waiting for my other
shoe to drop
I'm like okay cool we'll see how it
plays the help you know now listen I do
things I have a sneaker okay Swiss I
have a book I'll say bye but I don't do
anything to make anybody get like people
like dude the content to make them but
you wouldn't have even realized it you
wouldn't have even realized it but
everything you would have done for free
on social would have had subconscious
context to get him to pay for the $200
thing and one the end so that's it for
me that I'm happy to ask buy my [ __ ]
sneaker I just don't give a [ __ ] if you
do or you don't
I don't require you to and I don't
produce content or have meetings because
that got it people will guarantee you
got a book I'm like yes am I making you
buy the book - then get past the [ __ ]
firewall to get to the content I have no
idea if you're buying the book or not
got it so what I want is I want to keep
your purity so they [ __ ] with you heavy
why people and the second you turn that
switch they won't not to the same level
25% go [ __ ] yourself I always knew it I
knew that [ __ ] was gonna be that the
other 25 subconsciously like okay cool
cool cool and he they let him get his
heat but [ __ ] them right yeah I mean
that's real that's what the psychology
is there's only 13 answers it might be 7
to maybe 14 I'm not sure but I'm just
throwing out there you know what I mean
there's just not that many answers like
whoever gives most of the [ __ ]
audience wins that's why everybody loves
everybody in the beginning they're the
purest then [ __ ] hands get in the mix
so would you say with that with that
strategy is safe right
you got it right so you know somebody
like y'all charge $20 you will make so
much money you got all these people
coming in I'm just like I don't want to
charge them $20 I'm gonna charge them $5
any little but you're not making that
much money back he's like it's not about
the money until you're the most
important the most connected and
Budweiser comes along zou and says y'all
I got a million for you people aren't
smart they're trying to monetize them I
just want to love them everything else
will work itself out first of all I
always know how to make money without
them second of all I understand I'm
gonna have everybody I'll figure out how
to win when everybody on [ __ ] in
America loves me when the Jets go up for
sale everybody's got a dollar for me
that's how I'll buy it if I can't do it
myself
that'd be some the craziest [ __ ] of all
time imagine I live my life for next 16
yrs keep going like this whatever I make
my little nut but I come at five hundred
million short and America comes up with
the other five hundred million I think
so
so that's why when everyone's thrown
cynicism he at me I'm like I can't hear
you I get it of course
listen anybody who flips has been
program like that because the game is
dirty what you go to Marshalls for I
don't know what you going to t.j.maxx
for what are you going to Goodwill for
cuz I'm
make money [ __ ] what are you
doing right like what are you doing
spend that money and get that double
maximum retired only like like I'm like
no I agree I just want it like I said
I'm just trying to no no I know what
you're trying to do no I mean it's like
what you say it like in terms of like
give it away for free
being like relevant in terms of like
your aftershave people will love you
more so I'm kind of at that point where
people love me and I love them cuz I'd
be [ __ ] people
listenmi listenmi do you spend an hour a
day literally on live in Surrey and
Facebook and just answer people's
questions good so add it so add another
hour of [ __ ] face time do you do a
random [ __ ] secret like meet up with
80 people great how many listen but wait
I'm not judging I'm trying oh how many
times have you really said in three
hours come here and whoever shows up I'm
just gonna spit [ __ ] truth do it
every day here's what I'm saying do
everything that got you here huh do more
okay what you're doing is it sound like
this is what I tell everybody like
that's not much has changed Mike like a
lot has changed nothing has changed
these are the same [ __ ] meanings
right they're just they're just
different people man like it's just the
same [ __ ] the Mac Miller's and Wiz
Khalifa's and this is he hustles went on
to become superstars and the some of
them did it but it's all the same [ __ ]
for all the you know princes and frogs
some of the people you thought were
gonna be the biggest stars of all time
they got caught up some of the people
that you weren't sure they became the
biggest titty boy had to change his name
forever titty boy to me right just
change his name
you know you know like so happy right
now so anyway listen
it is also back to what that means for
you do what I'm doing and you will be so
[ __ ] big you will remember this
meeting for the rest of your [ __ ]
life always just give that's scale don't
try to make a dollar out of anybody who
follows you on the craft of this teach
them how to fish you know what I mean
keep teaching know what's your Samantha
honestly just keep teaching them and
then and then you do continue to do your
craft you know and that will work in
parallel and amazing [ __ ] will happen
the power isn't the attention
well what do companies want with cardi B
effect you got to host everybody that's
it and so whether that's cuz you're
pretty or cuz you're can you wrap a
ratchet or it could because you can dunk
or because you're thoughtful or cuz you
like whatever it is in the world it's
all the same game at the end exactly
what you two does and what Tiger Woods
does and what [ __ ] and you know the me
goes do it's all the same game it's when
it's all melted down it's just - how
much time did you spend paying attention
to periods and a story done sporting
events are long why are basketball
players more important football players
cuz you can see their whole face yep
like if I all in the NFL I would take
helmets off now and nothing do
concussions I just I just want people to
see von Miller's face more often will it
be different hitting yes would I give a
[ __ ] no cuz football would be bigger you
know why in Atlanta clubs football
players walking with chains with their
numbers on it cuz you know they are you
know thought are you know exactly who
that is saying [ __ ] like being it's like
the biggest war in the world they run
around with a debate that says [ __ ] you
can see what's it like glory so do you
understand so that's what you're
creating a my guy attention so basically
I just spent all my time working my face
off so I can make money other ways so I
can bring the most love so I can get
attention because I earned it because
I'm bringing value the end simple
hmm create no friction charging friction
not being on every platform friction
that's [ __ ] true people try to tell
me stop using Facebook I'm just like
what facts what I [ __ ] obsessed with
a spy what I said on Instagram all day
and do things doing Twitter on Facebook
at all oh oh oh
and when shits not poppin that's when
it's poppin yeah I'm obsessed with
snapchat right now it's crazy who so
many people got off snapchat though only
people I see on snapchat at him in
future yeah so like you got a bigger
platform
and now I see everything future Rihanna
stop messing with it everybody I'm
Esther Rihanna would just like yeah we
not use general that's fine now
hey you build a big audience for
everyone else that does through you and
guess what
15 euros are on there yup and guess what
they'll be 25 and 10 years in years
you'll be watching that for 10 years and
guess what sit down and get discipline I
can't write for [ __ ]
guess what even before I had people
helping me write like write a post on
LinkedIn write a business put you write
a business post on LinkedIn change your
whole game there's not a single [ __ ]
person no city is unlike then we not I
mean LinkedIn originally started as a
place where you could it was a job
platform where people were crowded but
now people are putting content and so
you there can go in with more of your
professor [ __ ] you go with a little more
culture flavor and Instagram you can go
a little bit different I'm ready if
there's so much to do where's your
podcast that good there's gonna be a
street where podcasters I'm good good in
the song but that's foot actions podcast
my good but yeah the end your writers
your podcast here we go you see what I'm
saying yeah
it's fun right and listen it's fun for
me too and I get different things from
like the old man and the [ __ ]
retirement home who teaches me about
life this is what listen as somebody who
thought he was the smartest and best of
all time of 22 experience [ __ ] matters
I couldn't give this a 22 its pattern
recognition I did this [ __ ] you got it
I don't think I'm better or smarter or
og or whatever I just think I lived
longer you would have gotten here anyway
I'm just trying to save you some [ __ ]
time you know it's you know like I don't
feel special I'm just trying to help you
just save you [ __ ] few minutes what do
you guys live Ohio or Iowa Ohio apart
mm-hmm Jesus you really love LeBron you
have to write like better you don't if I
lived in Akron I don't love brah I'm I
probably have a face tattoo of LeBrons
face over my own face if I'm from Akron
my god I would literally like transfer
everything I mean white it'd be weird
that's some racist [ __ ] I'm like I don't
give a [ __ ] LeBron
seriously in Ohio you never won a
championship and LeBron did it guys
you don't even understand it makes no
sense it's a fairy tale some movie [ __ ]
well some kids gonna grow up you know
I'll become one of the great basketball
players of all time and end up on the
cab's leave come back we'd be down 3-1
against the [ __ ] squad that was the
generational squad [ __ ] you LeBron's a
movie seven times over he drove by the
way by the way he was he was that was in
the works I don't know what happened one
of my killed some they couldn't make a
deal I don't know if it was definitely
it's really been interested you know
honestly probably the one thing
especially in your culture
the one thing I'm gonna give you a
really interesting piece of content for
you to think about it's crazy
where Jordans are in culture right now
you could have never told how long you
been in the sneaker game could you have
ever could you have ever imagined it
being less like this not this relevant
like it's relevant but like so much has
chipped away at it in the last five
years
correct
the late the chin is I'm saying now it's
cream Kanye divert to Nike stepping up
they stuff you got to be shine not a
shoe jay-z like there's so much
different stuff in terms like the
athletes got to compete with the
entertainers nothing just the first time
adidas has ever had like oh yeah come on
oh listen that's what I said Jordan went
to drink like you just saying why would
a brand won't cardi me because the
attention they could give Jordan knew
what they was doing when they went to
drink they went to drink because he was
the most relevant rapper at the time
that was on fire you got a rock in five
minutes Coolio see how I'm
great
so it works but nobody in the city and
would have thought it could have
happened this past this all happened
last three years yeah it what happened
real fast yeah real fast real fast he
was killing killer face jams you hope
somehow you can get a space yeah it's
not a single person in this room wearing
Jordans three years ago forty four to
five listen I've never listened I've
never owned a pair of Jordans cuz [ __ ]
him but but they're great sneakers and
they're still great and they play and
people wear them all day but not really
like they were the only thing people
were that was it
i warrior forces because I hated Jordan
that was it toy boy here from where we
knew it just in fact I know I know I
know but what about the st. Louis part
oh yeah I found that out later
Louis I was like damn that touches my
heart how far what part are you from I'm
from st. Louis II st. Louis's Illinois
it's much worse yes like economy I got
it you know there's there's level of
suck is sucked it was great Jackie
joyner-kersee she's such an athlete
Brownsville that's like the brown not
East st. Louis like the Browns will like
how would you go to like understand many
boys we got a good I'm glad you came
I'm real glad you came you know what I
mean you were about to graduate and that
graduation is actually the recession
think about basically triple down on
what [ __ ] got you there instead of
doing something completely different
oh the streets [ __ ] with you and then
you got put on and now you're in a big
time the streets you [ __ ] idiot
how the [ __ ] do you think you got better
so one more thing I know you gotta go
but I just my thing is this though would
you agree to say that first who dictate
is he who determines standards of say an
industry like so if I'm the first person
to be vocal about what's being said do
you think that that would basically set
the bar for any copycats or things that
would follow I think I think that
there's a land grab when you're first
and you're right that is great right I
think when it comes to copycat it's just
noise if you're better you win if kid
comes along the way and plays your
blueprint and he's better she wins
sorry you're sad that's what [ __ ] all
this angst and the rap game is I'm sorry
I'm sorry lil yachty was an Arkansas
state where it ever [ __ ] and [ __ ]
didn't like I get it that you've been a
[ __ ] I get that you grew up in a jazz
home and this is that but that's just
the way it is it just is what it is like
sorry you're like listen
and by the way honestly like I don't
think of it as hate or I really don't
worry bitterness I just think it doesn't
matter like I don't think they'll
understand I'm not looking at like the
old crowd and be like that's not real
music I'm like I don't look at his hate
I just don't think either is right or it
matters the market is the market is the
market everybody copies my [ __ ] I'm sure
I copy other people that that's not what
you're the first person to talk about
resale culture on the internet get the
[ __ ] out of here people are making
garage sale videos on YouTube and oh-6
like like that's all I was saying like
interns like but you always you always
like everyone's about themselves right
like kind of like you're not gonna be
the first you're not gonna be the last
and and just recognize that when you're
the best you just don't want to end up
Rocky three right because you're the
best you're the best and then you got
robots and then mr. t punches your
[ __ ] face off
the reason I'm [ __ ] working harder
and smarter and giving more as I know
I'm winning which means I'm vulnerable I
get it thank you you're welcome
which is why I know that - because it's
why you're smart you're saying okay look
I'm vulnerable now
the information is gonna get there
people coming up.i that you know you you
always know it right it's like an
athlete back to sports you knew and that
one kid you just saw something where
some kid was coming from even less than
you yeah and there's a little more and
you're like I know exactly what that is
you're like that was me twenty four
months ago and I know I can't beat that
cuz I got my off weights now I had a
nice meal so you said cool bet I'm smart
I'm gonna start building a different
thing
that scales I'm saying exactly but go
even higher well the end experience baby
right you'll be doing the same thing
when they experience span [ __ ] yeah
because I'm basically I want to do what
you do my you know the best part of
being an entrepreneur is you don't get
slow murdered Kobe got slower
LeBron's gonna get older yep that's just
life MJ's wizard MJ and the Wizards
wasn't that at the same engine you know
but for me I'm that mom now 42 I'm in
the best I'm in the prime
what happens with entrepreneurs they get
too rich and then they start trying
using money to stop the young bucks you
know always pay attention to the person
that's given the advice not the advice
you know he's telling you to charge 20
bucks non-winning players already know
that so when people like Gary like
people like sometimes in this moment
people like yo but my [ __ ] I'm like
you're saying the opposite [ __ ] I'm like
cool I'm like who's telling you the
other thing now now if they're like
Diddy then I'm like okay well then and
you have got to make a decision because
there's a million ways to win but 99% of
the time they're saying shitty is to
giving me that advice you know I mean